Chances are, most moviegoers didn't expect
to get their hearts broken by Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom.
After all, this is standard popcorn action
fare, featuring deadly dinos, bad decisions
by the humans, and a whole lot of fun.
But there was one scene that caused many fans
of the hugely popular adventure series to
choke up and walk away rather traumatized.
Click away now if you're still avoiding spoilers,
or you might be traumatized yourself…
"You're the one who made me come here.
I'll be alright."
The scene that seems to have gutted a lot
of moviegoers features Chris Pratt's Owen,
Bryce Dallas Howard's Claire, and Justice
Smith's Franklin escaping Isla Nublar just
seconds before the island's active volcano
destroys the defunct theme park.
While some of the dinosaurs have been transported
from the island by Ken Wheatley's salvage
operation, our trio of heroes spot a helpless
Brachiosaurus who has been left behind as
the clouds of smoke billow around and eventually
engulf the moaning animal.
Those who caught Fallen Kingdom in theaters
have since flocked to social media to share
their grief over the scene.
As one user put it: "Not to be dramatic but
I would die for that Brachiosaurus in Jurassic
World."
Another fan admitted that he was "lying in
bed thinking about THAT Brachiosaurus" long
after Fallen Kingdom's credits rolled.
One woman compared her outrage over the Brachiosaurus'
demise to the way some fans felt after seeing
Star Wars: The Last Jedi, and another was
left completely crushed after witnessing the
emotionally distressing sequence and wrote:
"All I wanna do is cry.
And all I want is a giant hug right now.
That scene had no business ruining my emotional
life.
I'm scarred."
Last but not least, at least one user had
reached the bargaining stage of grief over
the scene, writing: "I'd be less emotional
if [Chris Pratt's] character was eaten by
an Allosaurus which is then eaten by a Tyrannosaurus
Rex which is then eaten by a Mosasaurus."
Hey, there's still another sequel in the works,
so who knows?
That very well could still happen.
"Not yet, kid."
The brachiosaurus has always been among the
friendliest members of the dino kingdom in
the series, after being introduced in 1993's
Jurassic Park.
"Just think of it as kind of a big cow."
So it's especially heartbreaking to watch
this gentle giant collapse under such excruciating
circumstances, and director Juan Antonio Bayona
has admitted to capitalizing on the nostalgia
factor associated with the species.
He even played a sadder version of the Jurassic
Park melody over the scene to represent what
he called "the ending of a dream that started
25 years ago."
"It was all a lie!"
While we dry our eyes and try to scrub away
the image of the Brachiosaurus that's now
burned into our brain, we're left with one
hope: that the Jurassic World team doesn't
pull a stunt like this again in the third
movie.
Dinosaurs are people, too …
"Oh God.
OH GOD!"
"Tah-dah!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!